hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner taten welt
die wm steht fast vor der tür und wir
sind schon startklar wir haben hier
nämlich ganz tolle wm cupcakes und zwar
habe ich hier ganz tolle café crème und
hab farblich passend jetzt natürlich in
deutschland hier mit dem deutschland
land die kp klepper und natürlich auch
die sahne gemacht
das heißt da nicht eigentlich ein
schönes eissing genommen und ich werde
jetzt hier mal rausnehmen um euch zu
zeigen um was es hier heute geht und ihr
seht auch schon dass man diese cupcakes
richtig toll aus dieser form
herausbekommt und so sehen sie dann auch
ohne förmchen aus und ihr seht auch
schon wie schön farbenfroh die sind und
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man die
leckeren teile herstellt dann geht jetzt
mit mir ein dickes zuerst zeige ich euch
jetzt einmal die zutaten für den
rührteig und zwar braucht ihr dafür 100
gramm weiche butter 100 g zucker 1 150
gramm
eine zitrone davon nehme ich jetzt die
schale und ein bisschen vom saft ich
möchte es nämlich ein bisschen
zitronengeschmack mit dabei haben aber
ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn er einen
anderen geschmack wollt einfach die
zitrone weglassen und andere aromen
nehmen da gibt es auch so kleine bank
erhoben
da könnt ihr einfach nehmen was ihr
möchtet dann brauchen wir eventuell noch
einen schluck milch eine prise salz
etwas vanilleschote oder vanille zucker
das ist es hier und etwas backpulver
abschließen
backpulver gehört und was hast du damals
gebracht
das ist jetzt hast du doch eben gesagt
ein pilz
zuerst gehe ich jetzt die weiche butter
in einer rührschüssel dann gebe ich den
zucker mit dazu und lass das ganze
richtig schön weiß cremig rühren dann
gebe ich das ei mit dazu und das noch
mal schön cremig rühren
anschließend kommt jetzt noch die prise
salz
die vanilleschote mit dazu und dann
dürft ihr auch direkt das mehl mit rein
geben gemeinsam mit dem backpulver und
ich gebe daneben auch die zitronenschale
mit dazu und etwas zitronensaft falls
der teig jetzt zu fest ist könnt ihr
gerne noch etwas milch hinzufügen das
kommt eben darauf an wie groß war
nachdem das mehl dazu gekommen ist
solltet ihr nicht mehr so lange rühren
weil sonst der teig safest wird deswegen
wenn das mädel dazu kommen einfach ganz
kurz eingefroren bis vermengt ist und
dann ist fertig
ich werde es meinen tag in drei
portionen einteilen
weil ich ihnen dann einmal schwarz rot
und gelb einfärben möchte und das ganze
werde ich mit passten farben machen und
zwar habe ich euch ja schon mal ein
video über meine passenden farben
gemacht das waren meine regenbogen torte
und da habe ich euch auch erzählt was
eben meine passten farben von anderen
passenden farben wie zum beispiel von
wilden oder spice kitchen eben ausmacht
und ich habe jetzt mal zum spaß der
farbe von frames kitchen bestellt
einfach weil ich die ursprünglich
anbieten wollte einfach um eine
alternative zu meinen farben anzubieten
aber ich werde sie nicht anbieten aus
dem grund vielleicht habt ihr zuhause
noch farben von sketchen oder von wilden
zum beispiel und da macht einfach mal
den deckel auf und riecht man an der
farbe riechmann berichtet
die nase weg die sax gehört das riecht
gar nicht gern und im gegensatz dazu
griechen eben unsere farben gar nicht
also das könnte eben echt ich bin total
krass deswegen konnte ich dir auch gar
nicht benutzen
und ich arbeite ausschließlich mit
deutschen herstellern gerade bei farben
weil das finde ich schon schwieriges
thema ich möchte einfach nicht dass dazu
viele schadstoffe drin sind und im
moment arbeite ich sogar mit einem
deutschen hersteller anpassten farben
die ohne acht farben hergestellt werden
also die werden dieses jahr noch auf den
markt kommen da freue ich mich schon
richtig drauf weil es dann einfach
endlich mal farben sind die ohne akkus
sind
wobei ich sagen muss dass ich diese auch
gern verwendet weil ich einfach sehr
wenig benutze aber wenn sie natürlich
komplett ohne arzt sind ist es umso
besser
das habe ich hier meine passten farbe
und schnee mit sauberen löffel das ist
auch ganz wichtig dass ihr immer einen
sauberen löffel nimmt und nehme jetzt
einfach mal diese schon weh nicht
einfach nur so eine spitze berührte es
hier ein und es sieht auch das reicht
total sehe ich jetzt mein tag ich noch
ein bisschen zu fest deswegen gebe ich
noch ein bisschen milch mit dazu jetzt
überall
noch ein schlückchen
und da müsste auch wirklich drauf achten
dass ihr beim schwarz und beim brot eben
mehr farbe braucht und beim geld einfach
mit ganz wenig farbe auskommt und dann
fange ich jetzt an die muffin förmchen
zu befüllen und gebt jeweils jetzt
einmal gelb rein
dann in der oben drauf
und dann ein löffel schwarz
und dann füllt ihr einfach die förmchen
mit den farben weiter auf
ich will jetzt die formen so auf drei
viertel und schütteln sie jetzt ein
bisschen damit sich das ein bisschen
besser verteilen und so fühle ich jetzt
die komplett anderen vorne noch aus
meinem affin sind jetzt soweit fertig
ihr seht auch das sind relativ große
muffin förmchen und deswegen haben die
jetzt bei mir für acht stück gereicht
das heißt wenn er zwölf stück machen
wollt mit diesen muffin förmchen müsst
ihr die 15 fache menge nehmen und dann
eben da einfach zwei eier aber ich
schreibe euch einfach das genaue rezept
für zwölf stück auf meinem blog die
muffins kommen jetzt bei 175 grad für
etwa 20 minuten in den ofen
dann müsst ihr natürlich die stäbchen
probe machen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder
und zwar seht ihr jetzt hier nochmal
allem affing backförmchen ich habe hier
verschiedene länder wie deutschland
dänemark spanien österreich hier ist
eine ganz neutrale plattform einfach mit
fußball motiv hier haben wir england die
niederlande italien schweiz portugal und
frankreich und wir hier nochmal sehen
könnt hier eben diese alu beschichtung
dass es eben einfach nicht durch meine
aussagen außer hinter grünen das ist
eine ganz normale papierform sowie masse
immer kennt und diese art ovag formen
sind eben etwas dicker und bringen eben
keine feuchtigkeit durch
und so sehen sie übrigens mit der
geschenkverpackung aus also das kann man
auch ganz gut verschenken einfach schön
verpacken und finde ich ganz hübsch
und ich sehe jetzt hier auch das
schwarze sitz richtig intensiv geworden
also auch wenn euer teig nicht ganz tief
schwarz ist mit dem backen wird die
farbe dann eben noch intensiver besteht
jetzt meine muffins täter und lasst sie
komplett abkühlen
das ist ganz wichtig dass ihr die jetzt
nicht warm verwendet und daneben das
einzige noch drauf gibt weil ansonsten
zerschmilzt meine muffin sind jetzt
ausgekühlt und ihr könnte theoretisch
auch so lassen weil die sehne richtig
hübsch aus in der form und hier möchte
noch mal die form zeigen und zwar löst
sie sich richtig toll von den muffins
wie ihr sehen könnt theoretisch könnten
und auch mehrmals verwenden shopping
stolzen ein bisschen mut stimme auch
raus und ihr seht es sich nicht wie
papier das das da so eben dran kleben
bleibt
ihr könnt die wie gesagt zu lassen oder
eben zu cupcakes verarbeiten und das
werde ich nämlich machen
ich mache heute wieder eine frischkäse
buttercreme die mache ich immer ganz
gern weil die einfach nicht verläuft die
kammer dann mit den cupcakes zusammen in
den kühlschrank stellen und dann behält
auch richtig schön ihre form einfach
durch die mutter weil wir jetzt warme
butter nehmen und wenn sie später im
kühlschrank ist wird sie wieder fest ihr
braucht davor einmal butter puderzucker
und frischkäse und alle drei zutaten im
gleichen verhältnis also zum beispiel
jeweils 150 gramm
ich werde die zutaten jetzt zudem
topping verarbeiten und wettern die
muffins tqw das topping ist ganz einfach
herzustellen ihr führt einfach die
zimmer warme butter mit dem puderzucker
richtig schön cremig und dann kommt zum
schluss noch der frischkäse mit dazu
wird kurz eingerührt und dann ist das
topping auch schon fertig
dann verteilt auf drei gleich große
schätzchen und färbe dieses topping
wieder mit meinen passten farben in
schwarz gelb und rot ein
und dann fühle ich einfach die farben
jetzt hier ein und jetzt ich will dass
sie 10 uhr am rand teil
ich hatte jetzt bis hin zu viel gelb
eingespritzt um anfang deswegen spritzig
das kurz raus bis gleich
jetzt und dann könnte den cupcakes schön
damit verzieren
so sehen jetzt die fertigen cupcakes aus
und ihr seht sie sind richtig schön
farbenfroh und ihr könnt sie natürlich
in jeder farbe machen so wie er das
möchte
in jeder länder farbe ich finde so
richtig hübsch wenn ihr merkt ihm wohl
nimmt der creme wenn ihr etwas weniger
creme wollen nimmt er lieber etwas
weniger solche rezepte kommen jetzt in
nächster zeit auch mehr also jetzt kann
die wm beginnen wissen alle stadtplan
mit diesen cupcakes und ich werde jetzt
viele krieg rezepte vorstellen und
tatorten ein paar so kleiner schiff
kamen teile einfach alles was zur wm
passt aber natürlich auch herzhafte
gerichte damit wir keinen zuckerschock
regen
dieses rezept und die produkte verlinkt
ich alle unten in der infobox hier unten
wo info steht und da gibt es als weitere
und alle infos zu meinem blog und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken freue mich wenn ihr mein
video bewertet und dann sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bald neutrale nach
österreich spanien england frankreich
portugal schweiz
deutschlands getan hier noch besser
postiert sind die wenn man die
verpackung mit schwarzem schatz ich weiß
dass das schweiz ist das okay aber wieso
haben wir zweimal frankreich ist
eingespannt bin ich froh dass du aber
frankreich moorlandschaft manchmal
schwanger ist holländer